the new thing is that oh none of us will
be safe until everyone is safe so i want
to throw to this video this is a chicago
public health commissioner uh basically
saying that until everybody is
vaccinated in schools we probably won't
open or you'll have to mask up or we'll
wrap you in plastic let's see you know
do offer particular vulnerabilities uh
if there are younger children still who
have not had the opportunity uh to be
vaccinated that'll be something we'll be
looking at my expectation of schools
would probably be one of the last places
honestly um that we would not have mass
in place but if we can get to a point
where schools are 100 vaccinated that
would be the setting i i would be
particularly interested in and then
all right so to be clear first off it's
a it's a hundred percent impossible that
a hundred percent will be vaccinated
it's just not schools don't even have a
hundred percent literacy rates nowadays
right their their vaccine rate should be
congruent with their literacy rate that
would be hilarious um but not only that
but also i've read this stat four
hundred thousand times uh the the
morbidity rate for children five to
eleven is point zero zero two it's under
500 children and in many cases they had
all sorts of other problems and
everything else uh stu what do we do
about this idea though that you know
until everybody is vaccinated now we're
still gonna keep kids in masks i mean
i've seen my nieces and nephews in in
masks you know five six-year-olds uh
this is not how children are supposed to
grow up
yeah well the realistic standard of full
compliance is uh is really the thing we
should be chasing here there's you don't
get that anywhere on anything including
all the childhood vaccines uh that are
already in place with mandates in
schools you don't have 100 compliance on
those things you never will you know
every once in a while i try to put
myself in the mindset of the other side
right i for me i take care of my own
health i i that's how i see the world
right like it's my responsibility
it's interesting that the other side of
this sees
themselves as unsafe unless everyone
protects them
and that's it look if you look at it
that way it's a scary world to be in
right um but we have a situation where
they want everyone else to be vaccinated
they want everyone else to wear cloth
masks that do basically nothing there's
a solution here that's pretty clear to
me
which is yeah i got it
no i mean this is serious yeah
there is a solution where we have n95
masks which do actually do something and
have showed some actual difference when
you when you test them uh not only in in
labs but in real and real world
situations for various viruses around
the world and it the best part about
that is you are protecting yourself you
don't need everyone around you to wear
an n95 mask you just need to wear one
yourself and you notice the government
never comes out and recommends people
wear effective masks they just want
everyone to wear masks that don't work
which doesn't make any sense you know
this is the united states of america we
have to be able to sit here and say we
are responsible for our own health and
understand that people are going to have
different views if you look at go down
the cold aisle of your cvs you're going
to find all sorts of medications you're
also going to find all sorts of herbal
cures you're going to find all sorts of
stuff some of it you might think doesn't
work some of it the person next to you
will think that is that is going to work
we are at a situation right now right
now that 80
of all adults have already taken the
vaccine none are considering it have
already taken it 80 percent what on
earth did they think was going to happen
here you know there there has to be some
level of understanding of who the
american people are they're not people
that are just gonna bend over for every
one of your mandates they are going to
make their own decisions and if your
product is as good as you say it is let
it speak for itself and people will
choose it so last thought on this for
everybody to me it seems at this point
this has nothing to do with covid the
virus and hasn't probably for over a
year that it has something to do with a
much worse mind virus about humans
desire to control other people and how
quickly we all fold we all have ideas
that will stand up to the machine and
fight for what's right and say what we
think but we see how quickly people
don't do that allison do you think
that's like a fair assessment at this
point that there's another problem
that's not really covered like because
we're not really talking about kovid
this whole 20 minutes so far we're
really talking about the other problem
that covid has unearthed
it's the psychological warfare that's
going on right now i mean to stu's point
this is the conditioning that's been
taking place for the last year and a
half plus this notion that not only do
not have to take responsibility for
yourself and for your own health but
that you get to blame
others if you get sick that that is
insanity to me and this notion that
children should be wearing masks to
protect others like at what cost right
because at some point you have to step
back and say what are the ramifications
of this i mean the the american academy
of pediatrics declared a mental health
emergency for children in this country
we are seriously harming our children
with with these protocols that we have
put in place because of coba 19. so
there's clearly some sort of compliance
and control issue that's taking place a
conditioning that's taking place
especially towards our children i mean
we've talked about it time and time
again the data doesn't back any of it up
so what is this really about it's about
compliance it's about control and i
think the more we get into this pandemic
the more that becomes very apparent and
how about the irony guys that this is
this is somebody in chicago where more
children have died of gun violence this
year then of cobin 19. yeah you have a
threat to your children there and it's
not the virus it's the violence let's
get the chicago gun death numbers i do
this almost as a joke at this point
every week because it's so ridiculous
that obviously the deaths are tragic but
you're completely right nobody cares
about that because unfortunately they
don't like the racial makeup of who's
shooting who in this case so we'll get
the numbers on that in a sec lauren in
the meantime take it away
well i think alice is completely right
this is not about kobet this is about
control i mean just look at so many
different uh restrictions and mandates
we've seen that made absolutely no sense
if we actually care about the virus the
fact that you can take off your mask
when you eat in a restaurant but kids
who are stuck in school at their own
desks they need to keep their mass on
the entire day if we actually cared
about transmission we wouldn't be using
vaccine passports because you can still
transmit the virus when you have the
vaccine we would probably be doing what
a lot of places started doing early on
in the pandemic whereas you just take
someone's temperature because we know
that the transmission rates if you're
asymptomatic are so so low and you know
obviously you can't spread covet if you
don't have it this is all about control
i mean that's why you you even see that
online students who have no in-person
classes are still being i guess kicked
out of their universities for not being
vaccinated which makes absolutely no
sense and
i think what this has revealed is that
there is a shockingly large percent of
the population who is happy to go along
with whatever the government says they
want to play hall monitor tattletail
call the police on their neighbors for
having gatherings when they're not
supposed to and that is kind of like the
main problem that i see right now like
all right what do we do when we live in
a society where you know around half of
the people
don't want you to be able to make your
own choices they want to make those
choices for you what is the best way
forward how can you like live peaceably
together when the other side simply does
not want to let you be